on va lutter contre les changements
climatiques c'est là qu'il va agir
la caq demandé aux québécois de
patienter et d'attendre au budget et à
le déposer un plan concret beaucoup
dénoncent d'engagement je crois pas
tellement au père noël il faudrait
qu'ils abandonnent certains de leurs
promesses on va respecter nos premières
[Musique]
non mais j'aime le titre vos priorités
votre budget votre gouvernement c'est
pas le gouvernement de la caq c'est pas
le gouvernement du parti libéral c'est
votre gouvernement des citoyens vos
priorités votre budget voilà le titre du
tout premier budget cac risque de
l'histoire du québec premier budget pour
le nouveau ministre des finances eric
girard un budget important il va sans
dire pour le gouvernement de françois
legault
après les mots voici les chiffres
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont tomber beaucoup
de promesses qui ont été faites
la grande promesse était de remettre de
l'argent dans les poches des québécois
deuxième promesse miser sur l'éducation
remet de l'argent santé également
rétablir des taxes scolaires moins élevé
partout sur le territoire québécois
des places pour les maternelles 4-1 et
cetera et cetera alors dans quelle
mesure vous voyez les documents qui ont
été remis aux journalistes et aux
députés qui seront remis aux députés
dans mètres d'un 25e minute maintenant
copie de ce budget nos collègues
sébastien beauvais et gérald fillion
sont dans le huis clos
actuellement mais mes camarades rené
vézina michel si roger et alex
castonguay alex boissonneault pardon à
l'ex sont à québec montréal en cas de
michel c'est de rené bonjour à vous
trois bonjour bonjour petit tour de
table rapide je pense avec vous prenez
vous aller surveiller quoi avec
précision cet après-midi alors avec
cette chronique de surplus annoncé c'est
comme ça qu'on peut l'appeler ce budget
il va falloir voir l'adéquation entre le
surplus et le voir la hauteur de ce
surplus monsieur legault disait on va
remplir toutes nos promesses
il y en a pour deux milliards et demi en
campagne électorale
au revoir comment on va arriver à le
faire et déjà une idée des crédits le
sable ça grimpe assez substantiellement
scan aura pour tout le monde parce que
tellement droit présentation tellement
de groupes qui ont senti qu'il y avait
là de quoi se nourrir
alors on verra parce qu'il ya tellement
d'attendre contrairement au budget
fédéral où il y en avait à peu près pas
et aux abords finalement il
libre un peu parce qu'ils avaient dit
danse classique des attentes sont très
grandes
et ça serait pas étonnant que les gens
qui s'estimaient satisfaits compte tenu
de tout ce qu'on attend des chances et
roger le contexte bien particulier il ya
de l'argent cette année un gros gros
surplus on verra le montant exact de ce
surplus on parlait jusqu'à 5,6 milliards
de surplus
après paiements au fonds des générations
c'est énorme mais ça c'est pour une
année sans ça crée beaucoup d'attentes
mais ce surplus qui ne reviendra pas
nécessairement toutes les années non
c'est pas pour toujours et mots j'ai
hâte de voir la transformation de
monsieur gérard en bas qui est un
banquier normalement ces prix d'un un
politicien est à 25 ans est assis sur
une grosse montagne d'argent d'habitude
ça peut pas résister à la tentation de
le dépenser je note que les dépenses de
programmes vont augmenter de 5,8 pour
cent pour l'année prochaine or
malheureusement pour laquelle j'allais
voir leurs cales financier à ce
moment-là il parlait de 4,1 pour cent
d'augmentation alors c'est une
augmentation beaucoup plus substantiel
que le cadre financier ne le prévoyait
et beaucoup de gens disent les dépenses
dans le cadre financier de la cac qui
était sous-évalué de façon considérable
alors faudra voir mais si on regarde ces
chiffres là maintenant c'est on n'est
pas sûr d'en sur une pente qui permet
d'avoir des augmentations durable à ce
niveau là des critiques gouvernement
vous donner des chiffres là les gens se
demandent comment se fait-il qu'on peut
lui donner des chiffres
alex et que le budget des dépenses du
gouvernement ce qu'on appelle les
crédits d'un langage familier à québec
sont des fois donné déposé à l'assemblée
nationale le lendemain du dépôt du
budget aujourd'hui ils ont fait la
journée même
et ce n'est pas sous le coup du secret
budgétaire parce qu'il ya pas de mesures
fiscales lada cdma mesures de dépenses
de chaque ministère et vous allez nous
présenter des tableaux ça donne une
bonne idée de la couleur de la journée
si je peux dire donne de bons a été sur
le vérifier
vraiment si on pouvait publier ça c'est
effectivement pas une erreur de
l'assemblée nationale il avait fait même
le dernier
l'année dernière aussi l'oms à niveau
les tableaux c'est effectivement
intéressant parce que ça nous donne une
idée l'augmentation des dépenses en
baisse à la stratégie des dépenses dans
ce budget dit-on en bref des dépenses
2009-2013 que ça donne c'est en
éducation croissance de 6,1 pour cent
des dépenses donc pour ça on pense créer
250 nouvelles classes de maternelle
caprins pour la santé ni service
chaussures voyez croissance de 5,9 pour
cent pratiquement six pour cent à trois
cent des dépenses dont 3 millions
d'heures de plus en soins à domicile par
rapport à 2007 2010 8 900 lits et places
d'hébergement supplémentaires dédiés à
l'univers jeu voyons une bonne éducation
ce qui est présenté aussi c'est la
déclinaison de ce qu'on appelle le plan
québécois des infrastructures
il est pour 2019 à 2029 de 115 milliards
de dollars 6 6 milliards de dollars
supplémentaires dont on devrait parler
dans le budget et oui ce que ça donne
pour l'environnement c'est une surprise
parce que c'était police était pour
cette ligne là ans le 1er octobre
monsieur leubou ne pensait pas donné
tant d'argent l'environnement ça c'est
très clair il le dit lui-même s'est
réalisée dans les six derniers mois est
ce que ça donne c'est 16 milliards 600
millions de dollars sur 10 ans et voies
réservées et pour le transport collectif
les autobus électriques et des autobus
hybrides ou 6 et le voyez les gens la
capitale-nationale soyez attentifs
réseau vous si on vous donnait 5 vers ie
3 me à cinq clients 300 millions $
supplémentaires sur dix ans de 2009 à
2029 pour entre autres le fameux
troisième née entre québec et ligue à
l'est soit aussi c'est important et
challans parlé à quelques secondes pour
si les dépenses de programmes
augmentation pour 2019 2020 de 5,8 pour
ça si plus effectivement que les 4,1
constants dont il était question et
l'autre chiffres que vous voyez mesdames
et messieurs de 2014 à 2018 sur l'ère
libérale
en moyenne les dépenses de programmes
aura augmenté sur ces quatre années là
cinq années là en fait à 3,1 pour cent
et pour l'année qui ce qui commence ça
sera de 5,8 pour cent je vais tout de
suite entendent rené vézina chelsea
auger la turne est d'abord donc ça nous
donne une bonne idée santé éducation
environnement beaucoup plus qu'on
croyait
c'est sur 10 ans marqués 16,6 milliards
ça c'est le vieux truc dans l'île qu'on
met sur dix ans quand on veut gonfler le
chiffre mais quand même c'est de
l'argent
vos premières réactions rené on ouvre
les vannes et c'est particulier parce
que c'est vraiment et michel soulignait
et alex c'est vraiment une grosse
augmentation des dépenses à 5 8%
il va falloir remonter très loin en
arrière pour voir autant que ça il sait
particulier qu'on le fasse dans la
première année du mandat parce
qu'habituellement la mémoire étant des
uns étant ce qu'elle est on se garde
beaucoup de coussins pour la dernière
année du mandat pour le contenter tout
le monde et comme il ya beaucoup
d'incertitude dans l'air sur la suite
des choses
j'espère qu'on aura quand même mis des
réserves pour être en mesure de
continuer parce que rien de pire que
d'un que d'habitués des gens ont dit
groupe à avoir beaucoup de manoeuvres de
marge de manoeuvre et après devoir
comprimer alors ça serait important de
suivre mais le réseau de l'éducation en
éducation je rappelle la c6
d'augmentation le réseau de l'éducation
rené michel avait besoin d'air demandait
de l'herbe
il ya de l'air y en a beaucoup plus on
en aura besoin le stress il ya les
maternelles quatre ans mais c'est
l'ensemble du réseau les bâtiments des
écoles qui sont souvent vétustes
il va falloir investir beaucoup il ya
beaucoup de rattrapage à faire et je
regardais le plan québécois des
infrastructures 2019 2029
ces 115 milliards de dollars donc on
imagine que les l'argent va continuer à
rentrer et mon poids dépasse et chasser
oui parce que en éducation quand on dit
6,1 pour cent d'augmentation dans le
cadre financier ces 3,5
on a même beaucoup mais aussi aux créé
de nouveaux besoins de créer maternelle
4 ans est un gros morceau les
maternelles ça coûte ça coûte cher et
d'autre part il ya aussi de
l'infrastructure les écoles
tout le monde le sait sont en piteux
état au québec il ya du gros rattrapage
d'affaires là alors c'est un peu normal
qu'il y ait ces dépenses là en même
temps est-ce que c est ce qu'on pourra
est-ce que c'est durable
est-ce qu'on pourrait avoir sur ce même
genre de dépenses l'année prochaine
l'année d'après il à l'année électorale
après celle là ça c'est plus difficile
va pas avoir d'autre que ça fait dix ans
qu'on est en situation au ciel à et
marché qui va bien et qui est en reprise
beaucoup beaucoup de gens vous diraient
qu'on vous diront que rond sans avoir
sur un ralentissement économique plus
jeune je voudrais pas propre à un peu
prononcé l'autre bon air la récession
mais il ya des gens qui voient aussi à
l'horizon alex il ya et ont parlé
d'environnement tout à l'heure ce
nouveau chef le raconte la sortie qu'on
va trouver dans les crédits budgétaires
encore une fois
on parle de voies réservées aux parle de
transport en commun
et là il ya cette bataille pour le
tramway et de québec d'ailleurs le
premier ministre actuellement rencontre
le maire de québec monsieur la bombe
parce qu'on se demande comment on va
financer ce tramway qui est de 3,1
milliards québec donne sa part on
s'attendait à plus d'argent du fédéral
c'est à dire corrigé tas devait se
terminer la rencontre mais je vous
dirais une vingtaine au mieux que c'est
terminé
qui est juste de boire et juste la
banque doit aussi qu'il va réagir
sourire non c'est soit vous savez qu'il
est généralement expressif le maire de
québec ne semble pas très content la
rencontre que ce une impression chose
est certaine ce qu'il voulait pas
commenter la rencontre
à la sortie on lui a demandé ce qu'ils
pensaient tous seuils de protection
commenter tout de suite voulu parler
après budget cela étant dit il n'était
pas content non plus quand il est arrivé
à la rencontre de notre collègue
alexandre duval qui le vus entrer vous
allez le voir dans quelques secondes
là aussi on s'enterre à son expression
corporelle qui a des comptes à régler
même chose pour monsieur lebon s'est dit
un peu plus tôt qu effectivement y'a pas
grand chose qu'il peut faire monsieur
legault ne veut pas toucher aux
enveloppes que propose le gouvernement
pour financer le tramway le total
s'élève à 10,3 milliards 100 millions de
dollars québec est prêt à mettre un
milliard deux cents millions
on attendait dans le budget fédéral 1
milliard 200 millions souligné deux fois
elle en disant que ça va pour le tramway
à québec
est ce que propose le fédéral c'est 500
millions pour l'ensemble du québec on
pourrait consacrer au tramway est aussi
intense l'argent double manque 800
millions le si on veut faire ça on va
écouter les extraits à ce sujet là un
peu plus tôt c'était avant la rencontre
je le souligne monsieur labeaume en
parler on est conscient de ce qu'on peut
prendre complètement ce 500 millions pu
donner à une municipalité
mais s'ils ont décidé de le faire si
vous faites un petit calcul il
manquerait quand même 300 millions donc
gouvernement fédéral pas livré la
marchandise
l'esprit dans quel état d'esprit je suis
fort et les problèmes et ce matin le
premier ministre a été clair et ce
qu'ils n'avaient pas de solution nous on
va être au rendez vous on est déjà au
rendez vous évidemment ça demandera une
participation du gouvernement du québec
aussi de nos partenaires municipaux
mais je voudrais que dans l'immédiat il
ya quand même des sommes importantes
on sait que le gouvernement les
ministres fédéraux comment c'est un peu
impatiente et michel si roger petit
commentaire là dessus enfin sur demande
répétée de monsieur legault d'un côté là
on en envoie de l'argent là on développe
et apprécions dit vous n'avez reçu
prenez le développent et s'adaptent et
l'autre et c'est ça que le gouvernement
du québec impose certes fait raison dans
les municipalités
c'est un homme touche au projet tramway
à québec imaginez ce que madame plein va
dire ce qu'est le marchand va dire ce
qui est
le magot c'est ça le problème est
justement catherine gauthier qui est à
montréal les projets de transports en
commun parce que les gens seront
peut-être surpris ou agréablement
surpris on verra tout à l'heure de des
montants qui sont dédiés à
l'environnement dans ce budget parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de projets en attente
à québec à montréal ailleurs et qui qui
attend du financement
ah oui tout à fait en transport en
commun on en parlait plutôt d'ailleurs
valérie et plantes qui veut absolument
sa ligne rose mais parlons d'éducation
aussi et patrice parce que la commission
scolaire de montréal c'est la plus
grosse commissions scolaires du québec
et elle est ici et on se sent parfois
mal mal aimé la les commissions
scolaires par le gouvernement le go donc
on craint certaines choses d'une part un
manque à gagner à la suite de cette
uniformisation du taux de la taxe
scolaire et il ya beaucoup de besoins et
le parc immobilier ici à montréal est
très vieux les écoles sont vétustes
on manque de place aussi aider des
roulottes un peu partout comme à l'école
ici où je me trouve dans le quartier
heureusement avec une sauce scolaires
attendent de l'argent les syndicats des
enseignants aussi patrice entre autres
la fédération autonome de l'enseignement
qui dit on a beaucoup souffert de
l'austérité libéral on a fait trop de
compression il faudrait investir près de
900 millions de dollars avec ce nouveau
gouvernement
juste pour que l'école publique peut
évidemment se sortir la tête de l'eau un
petit peu il il faut revaloriser le
métier d'enseignant y manque des
enseignants et et oui on entendu que
c'était la priorité du gouvernement et
on souhaite que ça soit démontrée dans
ce budget ce sera le premier test dit la
f1 voici son président l'a dit on
perçoit dans discours du gouvernement
logo ou une volonté de réparer les pots
cassés en éducation maintenant c'est par
le budget qu'on voit si des moyens
seront mis en place pour réparer les
pots cassés donc ça ne peut pas
uniquement être que dans le discours
il faut que les gestes suivent et c'est
aujourd'hui le test qui va permettre de
connaître le degré de sincérité du
premier ministre bon l'autre aspect on
en parle un peu plus tôt parce que là on
a appris que l'augmentation en éducation
sera de 6,1 pour cent qui est quand même
pourcentage apprécié a beaucoup plus
élevé dans les durant les dernières
années donc à surveiller l'implantation
des fameuses maternelle 4 ans ce sera
surveillé en trop de justement par les
commissions scolaires qui vont vouloir
savoir combien on va leur donner pour
justement implanter ses maternelle là
parce que ça prend davantage de
ressources davantage de place aux six
essais surveiller aussi patrice par le
milieu de la petite enfance la
fédération des intervenantes en petite
enfance qui dit avoir fait le tour du
québec rencontré les intervenantes
rencontrer les parents et dire aussi il
ya beaucoup de parents qui n'en veulent
pas alors nous aussi on aimerait avoir
notre part du gâteau on voudrait qu'on
augmente le nombre de places dans le
réseau des cpe alors sosa va être
surveillé parce que ces gens-là se
disent contre la meute avec quatre ans
mais clairement c'est une promesse qui
va se concrétiser ou en tout cas qui
commence à se concrétiser par ce
gouvernement de france catherine
codifiant montréal merci alors une
petite pause même est sûre on revient
puis ce sera presque le moment où on
aura toutes les données de ce premier
budget d'eric girard a tout de suite
[Musique]
dans une dizaine de minutes nous
pourrons donc prendre la mesure de ce
premier budget d'eric girard et à
l'examen premier budget d'un nouveau
gouvernement il ya de la fébrilité à
québec
plus qu'une habitude alexz wigg
longchamp on sent qu'un changement de
paradigme réussi on sait très bien les
gens sont bien concept les étoiles sont
et demi en faveur du gouvernement donc
les attentes sont grandes et promesses
et est grande aussi d'envoyer des
représentants de la société civile les
représentants des municipalités des gens
qui parlent au nom des agriculteurs
parle au nom des chambres de commerce
aussi des entrepreneurs
ces gens là se rend au moment où l'on se
parle au salon bleu ils vont écouter le
ministre des finances par les présenter
son budget et tout de suite après mon
réagir évidemment les gens ça russie y
en a qui vont être déçus dans ce budget
là donc on attend de voir s'il pourra
répondre aux attentes sont très grandes
en ce moment ici l'exposition alex dans
quelle mesure on est au courant de la
façon dont on a travaillé au ministère
des finances avec le ministre bien sûr
nouveau avec le premier ministe des fois
les premiers sont très très près tout
près derrière leurs mines et des
finances puis survint est-ce que qu'est
ce qu'on peut en dire qu'est ce que vous
en savez ce que eric girard disait hier
lorsqu'il présentait ses espadrilles de
course ou donné c'est qu'il a travaillé
sept jours sur sept dans les dernières
semaines ça
mais fatiguée dit qu'il est fier de ce
qu'il a fait ce qu'il a beaucoup
consulté sur le terrain est allé voir
les gens pour savoir ce dont ils ont
besoin pour essayer de voir un peu où il
devrait dépasser la rabasse que les
surplus budgétaires mais voyez une 10
ans connu dans tout ça c est ce qu il va
y avoir beaucoup de dépenses récurrentes
ou si on voit investir l'argent tourne
en ce moment mais s'assurer que ça coûte
pas trop cher au bowling dans trois ans
donc on me suggérant essais je suis
surprise de voir les gens sur le terrain
ce qu'ils pensaient de travail est
réparti et il ya rené vézina faire le
saut entre banquiers y était trésorier à
la banque nationale et ministre des
finances et ça demande quand même ça
demande une adaptation d' acte et vous
partez d'un modèle où vous gérer pour
une entreprise qui doit dégager des
profits pour ses actionnaires
vous arrivez dans l'espace public où il
faut combler des besoins en essayant de
contenter un peu tout le monde
l'ensemble des parties prenantes c'est
un saut impressionnant mais bon t'as
l'air à l'aise on verra parce que c'est
pas un ministre qu'on n'a pas vu
jusqu'ici de cauchemar taille et il
s'est pas mis les pieds dans les plats
très bien mise les finances soient
indépendants ça peut se tromper mais
quand on parlait de dépenses récurrentes
je prends simplement les demandes des
municipalités du québec qui se
définissent comme étant le gouvernement
proximité savait qu'on est on avait
promis de leur donner un point de tvq
c'est à peu près deux milliards de
dollars par année
est ce que ça sera dedans ce qu'on
pourra s'affranchir de l'impôt foncier
comme on demande depuis des décennies
ces deux milliards ça continue est ce
qu'on pourra on est en mesure
c'est le genre c'est le genre
d'engagement on verra par les autres est
ce qu'on sera on sera capable d'aller
vraiment les contenter chelsea alex
qu'on sait déjà ce qu'il y aura baisse
de la taxe municipale ça c'est la taxe
scolaire
il y aura donc ce grand ménage qui avait
été promis aussi qu'il rende l'argent
pour reprendre l'expression du
gouvernement legault qui redonner aux
québécois dans la poche des québécois
celle ci ça c'est un incontournable on
le sait c'est télégraphié oui mais ce ne
sera pas nécessairement des baisses
d'impôts ya la taxe scolaire vous
10 il ya des allocations familiales ya
le retour à la vérification unique dans
les garderies ça pour le gouvernement
c'est de l'argent dans les poches des
gens des bessanais ça n'est bien sûr
mais des baisses comme tel d'impôt sur
le revenu je pense qu'on peut pas
s'attendre non pas maintenant et alex et
c'est pas dans les cartons d'ailleurs il
le disait aussi lorsqu'il parlait les
écarts de rendement d'hydro-québec non
pour lui c'est l'argument de dire on va
redonner de l'argent dans les poches des
contribuables
c'est la même chose pour ce qu'on
appelait les trop-perçus d'hydro-québec
mais ça va passer par un allègement du
fardeau fiscal avec d'autres programmes
dont ceux dont on parle et michel comme
par exemple le 8 dollars par jour pour
les garderies le retour à la fin tout
l'a fait la modulation tarifaire rené
vézina souligné nous s'il vous plaît le
côté inhabituel de l'exercice
aujourd'hui dans la mesure où les
surplus ça fait cinq ans qu'on couvre
des budgets à québec où on n'y a pas
beaucoup beaucoup de surplus là on
essaie plutôt dans l'austérité qu'on a
rattrapé pour le tenter de réduire les
dépenses le plus possible on est dans un
pour reprendre le mot à la mode j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure on est dans un
autre paradigme a écouté avec la
création d'emplois qui a eu au québec
quelques années avec des entreprises qui
font de meilleures affaires
li était clair qu'on allait recevoir de
mer rentrée conte adapté de mer rentrées
fiscales
mais à ce point et là ce serait étonnant
et il faudra voir vraiment jusqu'en
italie via les fai faut pas l'oublier il
les fait le des mesures de la rigueur
qu'on avait voulu imposer plus tôt on a
peut-être pesé un peu trop d'ailleurs
là-dessus mais il ya une résultante là
dans les frigos et les tarifs sont là et
oui c'est la résultante alors ça arrive
pas du ciel mais est ce qu'on est
capable de prévoir que cette belle
organique que cette belle machine ne
roulera à dents d'un gr dans l'huile
pour les années à venir
là c'est une question qui va falloir se
poser parce que je le dis commencez
d'entrée de jeu avec une augmentation de
départ aussi imposant c'est quand même
prendre un méchant paris très bien
michel si oui on le rappelle ce qui
n'était pas avec nous quelques minutes
grâce au dépôt du budget des crédits
nous savons
les dépenses des programmes vont
augmenter de 5,8 pour sa moyenne des
années libéral c'est 3,2 donc là il ya
un bon déjà qui est significatif
oui il ya aussi la bonne performance de
l'économie québécoise et de l'économie
canadienne vous savez il ya deux jours
au budget fédéral
il y avait plusieurs milliards de plus
que prévu dans les coffres du
gouvernement à cause de rentrées
d'argent supplémentaires de vouloir s'en
est servi pour faire des bonbons
électoraux mais je faisais le québec
fait partie de ceux de ce mouvement là
l'économie va bien les rentrées d'argent
du gouvernement sont bonnes alors c'est
peut-être l'année où on peut faire un
effort supplémentaire par exemple pour
le parc immobilier des écoles ou des
choses comme ça mais encore une fois
c'est pas durable de ces certains comme
comme croissance faudra voir dans les
prochaines années ce qui va se passer
mais c'est un fait actuellement c'est
vraiment une situation très intéressante
pour tous les gouvernements et
à ottawa monsieur morneau s'en est servi
de façon très directe et très électorale
gérald qui se joint aux géants fillion
vous étiez dans ce huis clos dont vous
venez d'arriver le secret budgétaire
n'est pas encore levé parce que le
ministre n'a pas déposé
si je comprends bien encore on le verra
dans quelques minutes
alors on peut quand même vous dire
bonjour on trouve par les dozos jauzion
jeu je peux vous montrer de budget parce
que nice l'a montré un petit peu plus
tôt alors un budget je vais me permettre
quand même de dire là un budget de de
taille moyenne n'a par rapport à ce
qu'on a vu au cours des dernières années
je peux pas vous dire ce qui est dedans
mais je peux être d'accord avec mes
collègues qui disent que l'économie vos
billets que des rentrées de revenus qui
sont au rendez vous et bien sûr ça a
permis au ministre gérard de présenter
un premier budget dans des conditions
très favorables
exactement il a les moyens il a une
marge de manoeuvre qu'on n'avait pas
connu au québec depuis cinq six ans au
moins mais plus que seul un oui mais je
me rappelle pas d'avoir vu mme sarr de
manoeuvre comme celle là le travail des
libéraux au cours des dernières années a
permis de dégager cette marge de
manoeuvre la croissance économique a
permis de dégager également cette marge
de manoeuvre et l'institut du québec
faisait ya quelques semaines on s'en va
vers des surplus de 4 5 6 7 milliards
avant le fonds des générations pour
l'exercice 2018 2019
donc c'est dans ce contexte là que le
ministre girard a pris possession des
finances publiques et a pu travailler à
mettre en place le début des promesses
de l'a4 le début de ce qu'il veut faire
pour l'ensemble du mandat
gerald logicien huis clos impôts pu
entendre ce qu'on a dit mais on ne vous
présentez quand même quelques données
présentées la croissance des dépenses
parce qu'on a déposé ce matin les
crédits budgétaires ils ne sont pas
frappés du huis clos parce que pas de
mesures fiscales de dans l'absolu on va
les remontrer aux gens qui n'étaient pas
avec nous un peu plus tôt des dépenses
de programmes qui décolle
santé de façon générale 5,8 pour cent
d'augmentation des dépenses de programme
pour l'année qui commence par rapport
aux 4 5 dernières années qui était à 3,1
donc un boom dans les dépenses de
programmes ça veut dire quoi ça s'avère
éducation 6,1 pour cent d'augmentation
il ya les nouveaux nouvelle classe de
maternelle quatre ans que l'on veut
financer santé services sociaux
croissance de 6% 5,9 pour être précis il
ya des 3 millions d'heures de plus en
soins domitien etc etc
environnement et ça c'est plus que ce
qu'on croyait ce con quand j ce qu'on
croyait ce que eux-mêmes croyait mais il
ya quelques mois
16 milliards presque 17 milliards sur 10
ans voies réservées transports
collectifs cetera autobus électriques et
hybrides
ils réseaux route si envahi m 5,3
milliards supplémentaires et ça comprend
le début de ce troisième lien entre
québec et lévis alors voilà ce qu'on a
pu donner c'est assez rare gerald qu'on
donne la même journée c'est arrive
souvent que c'est le lendemain et
surlendemain
selon l'elysée le budget des dépenses et
à tous les jours c'est à tous les jours
ses atouts budget c'est le même jour que
le budget la seule fois où c'était pas
le même jour c'est le gouvernement de
paul et de marwa le 20 février 2014 qui
n'avait même pas déposé de dépenses
avant de déclencher l'élection
j'ai même ri j'ai avant mais l'avons
bref le genre remonte au 20 janvier de
ses plus jeunes est arrivé avant parce
qu'il ya des contraintes parlementaires
qui font que des fois on est obligé de
déposer les crédits incertaines d'api le
budget n'est pas prêt mais il n'a pour
ne plus en parler
le budget des du québec est rendue
extrêmement complexe il ya des entités
consolidées des entités non consolidées
il y a un surplus avant le fonds des
générations un surplus après le fonds
des générations
il ya une réserve de stabilisation il ya
beaucoup de postes budgétaires fait que
les chiffres que vous venez de montrer
ce sont les chiffres qui sont dans le
budget des dépenses mais lorsqu'on
regarde le budget des opérations qui a
été présenté par eric girard ah bin là
l'émission change un peu parce que l'on
donne des informations des croissances
de dépenses en fonction des
mission alors j'espère qu'on ne va pas
vous ensevelir des chiffres qui vous met
les dangers représentés au vous serez
l'instant je serai là pour tous des
mails et bien sûr gerald alex là ça
commence les gens sont entrés oui les
gens sont tentés se déplacent rapidement
vers le salon bleu comme je disais ici
on sent la fébrilité les gens veulent
vraiment savoir ce qui va se passer
parce que ça va tellement bien comme le
disait j'ai râlé sur brûlons pas
tellement des surplus budgétaires que
les gens d'ici c'est pour maintenant je
reçois ce que j'aimerais recevoir quand
vais-je le recevoir d'ailleurs c'est ce
qu'il y avait un adulte bois c'est aussi
pour l'environnement il est long mais
vraiment on ne la pire crise
environnementale on est le plus gros
budget le plus gros surplus dont on
devrait pouvoir allier les dépenses
vraiment les attentes sont importantes
un qui va regarder ça me chercher en
visitant avec des yeux très particulier
c'est carlos l'état qui a présenté les
cinq derniers budgets
puis il doit se sentir un peu bizarre
aujourd'hui michel ce qui est le but de
ce billet ce gros show puis là le doigt
un peu à monsieur l'état en même temps
je pense pas que ça va arriver mais
c'est clair que demain 15 jours et
aujourd'hui comme chez les tangos parce
qu'ils accordent un critique financiers
du parti libéral va réagir il va faire
remarquer lourdement que si le
gouvernement
sa marge de manoeuvre s'est passé à
cause de ce qui s'est passé là le
dernier mandat
il y avait du pour et du contre la
dengue bien sûr mais c'est quand même de
l'acsa vient un petit mot sur
l'environnement seize meilleurs salaires
beaucoup mais sur 19,6 milliards par
année
c'est pas un énorme essayé et d'autre
part alex disait monsieur
je suis là bob le maire de québec avait
l'air un peu malheureux aujourd'hui
c'est peut-être pas juste à cause du
fait qu' il semble pas y avoir dans le
budget d'un jambon le tramway québec
c'est aussi parce qu'on met pas mal de
sous pour le troisième bien un projet
auquel il ne tient pas lui et [ __ ]
qu'il y voit que on va faire la
troisième nuit avant de faire son entrée
- c'est d'ailleurs ce que dit le parti
libéral je peux me permettre ce qu'on
dit c'est parce que ses revenus pendant
la période des questions ce matin est ce
qu'on disait c est ce que monsieur
legault vous voulez préserver les autres
enveloppes pour pouvoir payer le
troisième bien est ce que c'est c'est à
ce prix là qu'on va se passer par
exemple 2 du tramway dont aux libéraux y
avait des questions à se poser ici très
bien joué dans ce budget des
infrastructures de toutes façons c'est
un intérieur de ce budget on emprunte de
l'argent pour investir dans les
infrastructures
je veux juste ajouter un petit mot
patrie si vous permettez à l'isi le
ministre gérard a salué le travail de
son prédécesseur aujourd'hui il a dit je
retrouve des finances publiques qui sont
en ordre qu'ils sont en bonne santé et
c'est ce qui me permet d'arriver de
présenter ce budget là et de tenter de
bonifier la situation des finances
publiques au québec c'est assez rare que
des finances et bien oui mais c'est la
réalité en même temps on arrive à des
surplus on nage dans les surplus alors
le ministre gillard le bien reconnu
aujourd'hui et monsieur girard j'ouvre
une parenthèse qui a été traitée
candidat pour le parti conservateur
fédéral n'est pas partisan là c'est
quelqu'un qui est d'ailleurs lors de sa
première conférence de presse pendant
qu'on voit des images en direct au salon
bleu le président qui va prendre son sa
place qui va appeler le minet ce girard
donc commencé comme des mesures on va
l'écouter d'un jour sans plus tarder
monsieur le leader du gouvernement
président je vous demanderai de
reconnaître le ministre des finances du
québec s'il vous plaît monsieur le
ministre des finances
[Applaudissements]
juste avant vous permettez moi de vous
rappeler une règle claire il n'y a pas
d'applaudissements dans les tribunes
s'il vous plaît monsieur le ministre des
finances prononcera maintenant le
discours sur le budget monsieur le
ministre des finances
je vous cède la parole monsieur le
président je suis fier de présenter le
premier budget d'un gouvernement de la
coalition avenir québec un budget grâce
auquel nous un vice
nous investissons maintenant pour
maîtriser notre avenir
[Applaudissements]
monsieur monsieur le président vous me
permettrez de m'adresser d'abord à mon
premier ministre monsieur le premier
ministre je veux vous remercier de
m'avoir confié l'important dossier des
finances dans le gouvernement que vous
dirigez grâce à cette confiance
j'ai l'honneur de servir les québécois
dans des fonctions stratégiques au sein
de l'équipe gouvernementale m'avait
confié en même temps une lourde
responsabilité
une responsabilité que je partage avec
l'incroyable équipe du ministère des
finances et mon cabinet cette
responsabilité je les accepte et avec la
volonté de mettre mes compétences mes
efforts au service de tous les québécois
nous gouvernons pour tous et sous votre
direction
nous sommes avant tout guidé par
l'intérêt supérieur du québec en octobre
dernier nous avons trouvé des finances
publiques en bon étant ses finances
publiques nous allons continuer de les
améliorer avec votre appui
monsieur le premier ministre j'ai la
ferme intention de faire en sorte que
notre situation économique et financière
progresse que le québec réalise ses
ambitions et que tous les québécois en
profite
je souhaite maintenant m'adresser à
l'ensemble des québécois pour leur dire
le budget que nous présentons
aujourd'hui c'est votre budget
au cours des derniers mois mes collègues
et moi avons écouté la population
tout au long de ce processus nous avons
été guidés par un principe fondamental
c'est à cet argent que nous avons le
privilège et la responsabilité de gérer
c'est celui des québécois les finances
publiques que nous administrons ce ne
sont pas les finances du ministère que
je dirige ni celle des autres ministères
ce ne sont pas les finances de nombreux
groupes d'intérêts concerné par les
décisions gouvernementales
il s'agit d'une évidence que l'on a trop
tendance à oublier
et que je veux souligner les finances
publiques dont fait état le budget que
nous présentons aujourd'hui ce sont les
finances publiques de tous les québec ce
sont les finances publiques de nos
familles de nos enfants comme de nos
usines
ce sont les finances publiques des
québécois des grandes villes comme des
villages de la métropole et de la
capitale nationale comme des régions ce
sont les finances publiques de nos
entrepreneurs et de nos travailleurs
ce sont les finances publiques
transmises par nos prédécesseurs et dont
nous sommes fiduciaire pour les
prochaines générations
jeudi également tous les québécois
votre budget a été défini à partir de
vos priorités
celle-là même énoncé par le premier
ministre dans son discours d'ouverture
votre budget répond prioritairement à
vos besoins en éducation en santé on a
connu en économie il améliore votre
pouvoir d'achat
en réduisant le fardeau fiscal avec ce
budget nous répondons aux préoccupations
immédiates des québécois et nous
préparons l'avenir nous retournons plus
d'argent dans le portefeuille des
québécois
nous donnons la priorité à la réussite
de nos enfants nous consacrons tous les
efforts pour que les ennemis soient
traités de façon exemplaire et pour que
les québécois bénéficient d'un accès
rapide aux soins de santé
nous agissons sur les investissements et
l'offre de travail pour augmenter alors
voilà monsieur gerra qui poursuit la
lecture de son discours du budget gérald
fillion allons-y avec les faits
saillants de ce but
derek gérard oui exactement donc c'est
un sur un budget qui est un équilibre
budgétaire on est au déficit zéro pour
le budget 2019 2020 sur des revenus de
115 milliards de dollars et des dépenses
de 113 milliards de dollars au fonds des
générations on injecte 2 milliards 500
millions
donc après le versements au fonds des
générations on est au déficit zéro
je vous ai mis les 2018 2019 pour vous
montrer qu'on a fait sur plus de 2
milliards 500 millions et avant le fonds
des générations et à 5 milliards 600
millions pour faire le point sur ces
chiffres là là les chiffres finaux pour
2018 2019 jusqu'à temps qu'ils aient une
révision au mois de juin
alors ça c'est le premier tableau que je
vais vous présenter les faits saillants
maintenant quatre faits saillants
pas de baisses d'impôts phase de baisse
de tvq il y à des âges et allègements
fiscaux mais on n'a pas de baisses
d'impôts ça viendra plus tard a dit le
ministre en santé plus d'argent pour les
soins à domicile et plus d'argent
également pour embaucher davantage de
personnel soignant
ça c'est pour le secteur de la santé qui
est l'un bien sûr des des segments les
plus importants du budget du québec qui
est le plus important avec l'éducation
également où on va injecter davantage
d'argent dans les services spécialisés
les classes spécialisées maternelle 4
ans un premier engagement pour 250
classes en septembre 2019 s'est confirmé
mais on ne veut pas aller plus loin sur
l'engagement jusqu'à 5000 maternelle ont
dit que ça va dépendre de la demande et
du succès des maternelles quatre ans et
des 60 ans un nouveau crédit d'impôt qui
en remplace un autre qui s'appelle le
crédit d'impôt pour la prolongation de
carrière pour permettre aux gens de
rester au travail et d'avoir un gain
financier à rester un avantage financier
à rester au travail à 60 ans 61 jusqu'à
65 et peut-être même plus donc développé
un peu sur l'éducation et la santé là
les deux les deux facteurs les plus
importants
oui une croissance des dépenses qui est
assez forte en éducation et en santé
pour 2019 2020 de plus de 5%
mais en 20 21 ça va baisser on va tomber
à 3 7% pour l'éducation il ya qu'à
virgule 1% pour la santé et regardez les
autres ministères quatre et demi pour
cent d'augmentation des budgets en 2019
2020 mais ça va tomber à 2 % en 2020 21
dont un coup d'accélérateur je vous
dirai pour cette année comme on l'avait
fait dans le dernier budget l'état aux
mets un coup de frein pour les années
d'après on veut jouer davantage sur la
prudence mais on nous dit qu'on dépasse
donc les coûts de système même en 2020
2021 le ministre maintient qu'il dépasse
des coûts de système en santé c'est 280
millions de dollars de plus qui sont
injectés dans les soins à domicile
la cac avait parlé de 200 millions nets
à 280 millions les besoins sont là ils
sont criants ils seront de plus en plus
important et on ajoute aussi du
personnel soignant investissement
supplémentaire de 200 millions de
dollars pour ajouter du personnel
soignant en éducation les services
spécialisés le soutien aux élèves les
classes spécialisées également les
milieux en difficulté 92 millions de
dollars supplémentaires
les maternelles quatre ans et 36
millions pour ce budget 250 nouvelles
classes en septembre 2019
toujours lié à l'éducation l'enfance la
contribution additionnelle pour la garde
d'enfants est à dire le tarif une et
plats pour revenir au tarif unique on
confirme les chiffres le les gens auront
droit au tarif unique en garderie si
votre revenu familial est inférieur à 78
1320 dollars cette année
après ça c'est sans 8530 dollars en 2021
vous avez droit au tarif unique si votre
revenu familial est inférieur à 140
milles et à partir de 2022
ce sera le tarif unique pour tous les
parents qui ont des enfants dans les
centres de la petite enfance la taxe
scolaire la réduction commence le 1er
juillet 2019
elle sera uniformisé en 2021 coûts
annuels prévue de 800 millions de
dollars
donc ça c'est tout ce qu'ils avaient
déjà été annoncés sur ça c'est
exactement ce qu'on avait promis n'est
ce pas oui exactement on est vraiment
lié sûr
la promesse les annonces jusqu'à
maintenant ça a été presque la première
annonce du gouvernement legault qui
avait déjà déployé un peu cette mesure
sur une uniformisation de la taxe
scolaire dans l'énoncé économique
vous nous parlez d'une mesure pour
garder les gens de 60 ans et plus au
travail
c'est assez fondamental c'est patrice
parce que d'un budget on voit clairement
que le bassin de travailleurs va baisser
au québec pendant qu'il va monter en
ontario donc faut trouver des solutions
pour avoir des travailleurs et même que
ça ralentit l'économie on commence déjà
le constater ce crédit d'impôt pour la
prolongation de carrière sera admissible
à partir de 60 ans en ce moment il ya
une mesure qui est admissible à partir
de 61 ans donc on la devance à 60 ans et
pour une personne par exemple qui gagne
c'est pas autour de 15 mille dollars où
ils ne paient pas d'impôts mais on va
ajouter dix mille dollars donc sur les
premiers 25 mille dollars il n'aura pas
d'impôts à payer donc ça pourrait aller
jusqu'à 1500 dollars de réductions
d'impôts dont convient vraiment bonifié
de façon importante ce crédit d'impôt
pour encourager les gens à rester en
quelque sorte sur le marché du travail
autre mesure on a parlé d'environnement
il ya quelques minutes le programme
rouler vert demeure
il est prolongé jusqu'au 31 mars 2021
ce qu'on dit c'est que ça va permettre
l'achat au québec de 66 mille véhicules
électriques de plus l'ajout de 27 mille
cinq cents bornes de recharge à domicile
et 1200 bornes de recharge au travail
après 2021 la subvention de 8000 $ qui
est accessible sur une auto en ce moment
de 75000 va passer à 60 milles dont on
va modifier le programme rouler vert à
terme mais il existe toujours jusqu'en
2021 dans sa forme actuelle et
infrastructures transports etc
ouais infrastructures on ajoute 15
milliards de dollars dans le programme
des infrastructures 2019 2029
donc ça veut dire qu'on fait passer ca
de 100 à 115 milliards de dollars pour
construire de nouvelles écoles
les nouvelles classes de maternelle
quatre ans les maisons des années il ya
des premiers engagements dans le budget
l'agrandissement de l'hôpital de la
malbaie et pierre le gardeur le
troisième lien entre québec et lévis le
tramway et de québec on ajoute à l'étude
le prolongement de la ligne jaune à
montréal avec un transport collectif qui
est à déterminer
un transport collectif pour l'est de
montréal également pour le boulevard
taschereau à longueuil et on planifie
aussi la réfection du tunnel ville-marie
et viger deux sommes très importantes
pour les entreprises un milliard de
dollars pour former une équipe
d'intelligence et expertise pour mieux
protéger les sièges sociaux
on pense particulièrement à snc lavalin
qui préoccupe dont l'avenir en préoccupe
énormément
le premier ministre françois legault et
on ajoute un milliard à la
capitalisation d'investissement québec
c'est 20% de plus à sa capitalisation
pour attirer des investissements au
québec de l'étranger pour investissement
québec on va définir la réforme au mois
d'avril c'est le ministre fatigué bonne
qui va l'annoncer et je les mets un peu
loin cette mesure là mais elle est
fondamentale
l'intégration des immigrants 146
millions de dollars de plus parce que on
veut développer un parcours
d'accompagnement et améliorer la
francisation des immigrants
ça aussi ça fait partie des solutions
pour augmenter le bassin de main
d'oeuvre au québec
et là c'était la ferme aux formules les
à en accueillir - mais les accueillir
mieux et avec plus d'argent donc c'est
ça que le budget nous dit on en
accueille moins on en accueille mieux et
avec plus d'argent
la dette brute est à 200 milliards de
dollars c'est 46,1 % du pib en 2020 ce
sera 40 5% du pib je vous rappelle qu'on
prévoyait 2000 26 ans pour le 45 % donc
la dette baisse beaucoup plus rapidement
compte tenu des surplus des années
passées le fonds des générations etc
gerald de mercy rester là gerald
sébastienne bonjour à vous j'ai rangé
mes questions avant de parler de
l'aspect plus politique
le surplus de 5,6 je crois vous m'avez
dit le surplus en fin de l'année
18 2019 avant le versements au fonds des
générations n'a fait quoi avec le tout
mis dans le fonds des générations
quel pc d'argent c'est à dire que le
fonds des générations va chercher une
partie du 5 6 milliards donc il reste 2
milliards 500 millions
en vrai sur plus et c'est de l'argent
qu'on met de façon comptable dans ce
qu'on appelle la réserve de
stabilisation
c'est une somme qui peut servir à
équilibrer le budget en fonction de la
loi sur l'équilibré budgétaire
et ça c'est rendu 10 milliards cette
réserve de stabilisation
je vous dis là on nage dans les
milliards de dollars quand on regarde le
surplus de la dernière année le
gouvernement vraiment les coudées
franches pour aller de l'avant puis
augmenter ses dépenses comme il neuf
comme il ya décidé de le faire
aujourd'hui ce que vous dites mais on y
va avec prudence en même temps et le
ministre que je vous le ferai entendre
tantôt mélinée gérard nous a dit on veut
baisser les impôts on veut baisser les
impôts d'ici la fin du mandat ou
l'annoncions en campagne électorale pour
le prochain mandat on pense déjà à celui
d'un semble-t-il très bien gérald rester
là évidemment sébastien bonjour à vous
alors premier budget toujours important
ça donne le ton ça marque un changement
on l'a beaucoup souligné depuis le début
de cette émission ils sont arrivés quand
même ils ont ils ont vu que la situation
financière était enviable était bonne
avec des marges de manoeuvre
alors quelle est l'empreinte la cat là
dessus on la cherche un peu l'emprunt de
la cac
bien honnêtement patrice on a
l'impression qu'un ministre libéral des
finances aurait pu présenter à peu près
le même budget avec les mêmes marges de
manoeuvre on réinvestira qu il soit
venir québec dans les missions
fondamentales de l'état se dire la santé
l'éducation et même quelqu'un qui a
prononcé les mots budget centre gauche
pour qualifier le budget de monsieur de
monsieur girard alors on s'entend on
s'entend on voulait pas nécessairement
avoir un feu d'artifice dans les tons de
bleu poudre de la coalition a mené à
québec mais on aurait pu penser qu'il y
avait eu un changement d'approché dans
ce premier budget parce que le premier
budget d'un gouvernement permet de jeter
les bases d'une vision gouvernementale
d'une nouvelle vision gouvernementale et
l'a4 nous et aimant vendu le vendre
changement qu'on cherche un peu ce
changement on a l'impression qu'on est
un peu plus dans la continuité
et quand on demande à monsieur gérard le
ministre des finances en quoi son budget
se différencie d'un budget qui aurait
peut être représenté par un ministre
libéral des finances avec les mêmes
marges de manoeuvre voici ce qu'il nous
répond c'est que notre budget réalise
les engagements de la cac en capital
nous nous sommes déterminés à réaliser
nos engagements ce qui est dans le
budget c'est ce que nous avons promis
aux québécois c'est ce que le premier
ministre s'est engagé à faire alors nous
remettons de l'argent dans le
portefeuille des québécois
nous mettons l'emphase sur l'éducation
les aînés se sont imposées l'année les
aînés ses soins à domicile on donne un
coup je pensais 280 millions jamais me
disait autre chose que malgré des allées
chercher que l'on voit derrière plus de
personnel soignant aussi on a
l'impression que c'est un peu le budget
de marguerite blais dans le fond parce
que les aînés on n'avait pas
nécessairement venir comme une priorité
or monsieur gérald j'ai visité à ch est
celle d un moment donné avec marque
belge été frappé par le rôle des
prochains dans par exemple les soins que
ça nécessite donc il ya une
préoccupation pour les aînés d'ailleurs
les gens les représentants de la fadoq
la lapidation des aînés du québec
diack stopper de noël au mois de mars
pour eux parce qu'ils s'y attendaient
eux mêmes pas nécessairement ça les
partis d'opposition eux relève sa et
disent que c'est une bonne chose de
prendre d'abord comme préoccupation les
aînés mais en même temps les libéraux
disent faites attention parce que oui
l'argent dépensé cette année mais dans
les années qui vont venir il va y avoir
un ralentissement de l'économie donc les
marges de manoeuvre seront moins élevés
et les deux autres partis d'opposition
québec solidaire parti québécois met
l'accent sur l'environnement
oui à des mesures environnementales mais
ça va pas assez loin la coalition bois
québec a pas cette conscience
environnementale qu'elle devrait avoir
voici donc en rafale les réactions des
parties de possibles l'année
19-20 donc l'année du budget c'est un
peu la dernière année de la dernière
année des marges de manoeuvre
profitez-en bien parce que je pour les
années suivantes sera peut être ça du
tout pas un plan de lutte aux
changements climatiques
c'est une opération de marketing
d'ailleurs dans les documents que l'on
vous a vomi on a fait un petit peu de
gris noir ou greenwashing avec des bots
petit logo comme ceux ici peu comme sur
les boîtes de céréales contient plus de
fibres ici ça contient des mesures
vertes
il y en a pas de mesures vertes en
réalité dans le budget de la coalition
bois québec aujourd'hui on dispose
d'immenses surplus mais ils font les
mauvais choix
la caq fonce tête baissée dans les
maternelles à 1 milliard mais réduit le
budget de construction des cpe la caq
dépensera un milliard pour les maisons
des années mais tu es capable de
s'engager pour rénover à tous jeunes
avaient tous les sachets soldés alors
vous dites c'est intéressant sébastien
vous dit dans le fond l'impression vous
avez eu que d'autres ont eu chômage
insee
ça aurait pu être le budget l'état aux
1,6 là d'une certaine façon il n'y a pas
de rupture en tout cas voilà c'est dans
la continuité ont réinvesti dans les
missions essentielles de l'état puis en
même temps c'était important réinvestir
en éducation c'est important de
réinvestir en santé aussi les
augmentations sont assez porte là autour
de 5,5 et demi pour sa de
réinvestissement dans ces deux secteurs
là qui sont les bases les les secteurs
d'activité pour le manteau du
gouvernement en économie ballet ont
réinvesti en a comme préoccupation aussi
la main d'or la pénurie demandeurs donc
il ya des mesures qui sont intéressants
pour les compagnies mais on nous avait
tellement vendu de changement dans la
proche de la coalition avenir québec
peut-être qu'on s'attendait à un peu
plus dans l'approché le changement
d'approché
on a plus l'impression qu'on est dans la
continuité d'un budget qui jouit
d'énormes surplus budgétaires et pour
lequel le ministre des finances avait le
moins les moyens de ses ambitions
rené vézina michel sûr j'y joue
vous rejoignez cette conversation de
l'économie rené alors première
impression que j'ai pu regarder ça un
peu oui effectivement
quand on dit qu'on danse dans l'argent
si vous avez la réserve de stabilisation
si vous avez le fonds des générations
en passant on continue de mettre
l'argent dans le fonds des générations
dont la valeur atteignait récemment
autour de 13 milliards on ajoute de deux
milliards et demi ça commence à faire un
bon pactole et qui pourrait être
éventuellement appliqués à la dette pour
réduire sa fameuse dépendance le ratio
pib à c'est intéressant
c'est intéressant qu'on puisse y arriver
il ya peut-être un élément sur lequel va
revenir le gouvernement disait on va
remplir tous nos engagements d y en ait
un engagement qui est pas remplie dont
je parlais précédemment
c'est le fait de redonner aux
municipalités un point de pourcentage de
la tvq qui aurait permis peut-être de
d'alléger la dépendance à l'impôt
foncier puis éventuellement permettre
aux municipalités réduire eux mêmes leur
taux de taxation foncière
ça y est post étonnant on dit qu'on va
des cons il y aura d un nouveau pacte
fiscal qui va être discuté avec l'auteur
noyade est grande
oui c'est ça des négociations à l'otan
ça fait longtemps que des négociations à
dix ans ça va peut-être un peu déçu
l'autre élément que je retiens c'est que
savez dans le budget fait en fait
souvent dans les budgets
il ya des annonces mais ça c'est shon
sur 5 10 15 ans comme on l'a vu fédéral
pour internet en 2030 mais dans ce cas
ci il ya déjà des actions dès à présent
oui la taxe famille ça va être graduelle
mais ça commence sans tarder et ça c'est
un changement de ton par rapport à ce
qu'on entend souvent très bien
appréciation analyse général michel
sujet avant de passer à d'autres mesures
avec gérald oui moi je voulais revenir
sur les municipalités parce que ça
c'était quelque chose que tous les
partis politiques sont allés dire au
maire au congrès du invaincu pendant la
campagne électorale reponsable
l'intérieur de la tvq ça s'en va chez
vous c'est réglé c'est fait pour tout le
monde et là on dire on va négocier
simple plus tard et 6e des séries perdre
là-dedans c'est beaucoup les
municipalités parce que les sommes
qu'ils les investissements considérables
sont dans les missions de
additional de l'état c'est à dire la
santé l'éducation les années maintenant
mais par exemple pour le transport pour
des choses comme ça les investigations
ils sont là il ya un accord mais c'est
moins important et c'est moi il ya moins
d'augmentation de ses budgets la chaleur
je pense qu'on s'attendait entre autres
à montréal goût il ya un problème de
congestion majeur on s'attendait à de
l'aide de ce côté là très bien j'aime
les saintais je veux gira de la conque
rapidement le prix vous avez une part
non mais ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'avant de parler d'autres mesures les
aînés je pense que sébastien nous le
disait bien le les aînés grand gagnant
est dans les 6 h et celle des et dans
les services des soins demi siem société
portant exactement plus de lits plus de
lits plus de personnel soignant et plus
de soutien à domicile donc effectivement
c'est important et pour les aînés qui
travaille toujours ou en tout cas qui je
sais pas peut-être que je comme un crime
de lèse majesté en parlant des nés à
partir de 60 ans mais à partir de 60 ans
pensait pas vous mais mais effectivement
le crédit d'impôt il est là pour
permettre un allègement fiscal pour que
les personnes de plus de 60 ans ou à
partir de 60 ans et le goût de continuer
à travailler
alors ça c'est vraiment à ça c'est ça
c'est intéressant et en tout cas il ya
quelque chose de nouveau là et en
éducation vous l'avez dit ou sur cette
année on n'a même pas mal plus il ya
bien sûr les maternelles quatre ans que
l'on doit financer
il ya aussi d'aidé du personnel de plus
que l'on souhaite dans les
établissements et du service spécialisé
dans le soutien aux élèves de travail du
travail de psychologue également il ya
beaucoup de travail là dessus on aurait
souhaité
l'opposition en parlait qui est plus ce
qui est de l'argent pour les enfants
handicapés parce qu'il en avait parlé ça
ça va tarder un peu ce déploiement
mais on dit quand même soutien aux
élèves réduire le nombre d'élèves par
classe également par enseignant alors ça
c'est c'est dans le budget sur
l'éducation il ya des gens qui nous
disaient qu'on investit beaucoup dans le
béton en retour la met en même temps
beaucoup d'écoles ont besoin de
rénovations qui sont importantes
très bien on l'a beaucoup dit depuis le
début donc dû à un surplus qui est un
énorme en fin d'année au 31 mars qu'on a
mis l'enfant du génération on a gardé un
2 5 milliards pour la dette et ce qui
fait que l'on prévoit l'an prochain quoi
gérald on prévoit 2 milliards 500
millions avant le fonds des générations
on le met dans le fonds des générations
on est à 0
pour ce qui est du solde faut comprendre
qu'on a dépensé beaucoup d'argent durant
le mois de mars en 2019 il ya un
milliard 600 millions dont les 250
millions qui ont été annoncés hier pour
les taxis ça c'est d'en haut mais ça on
paye tout ça dans le budget 2010 8 2010
on utilise des surplus pour payer les
taxes joncquez ces bons est exactement
il ya une liste comme ça d'une trentaine
de mesures à gauche à droite en
intelligence artificielle dans les
entreprises en entrepreneuriat dans les
régions toutes sortes de petites mesures
qui ont été pelleter je vous dirai dans
l'exercice 2018-2019 dépenser au mois de
mars 2019 pour faire fondre en quelque
sorte que ce surplus budgétaires et donc
d'entamer la nouvelle année sur de
nouvelles bases pour les revenus et les
dépenses surgira monsieur legault elle
l'avait dit à plusieurs reprises c'est
pas vrai là qu'on a des surplus a pu
finir mais il y en a quand même des
surplus importants n'y a pas un
gouvernement au canada qui dégage des
surplus budgétaires dans ces opérations
revenus dépenses comme le gouvernement
du québec
mais le taux de dette du québec il faut
quand même le rappeler à chaque fois est
plus élevé que le gouvernement fédéral
par exemple un déficit d'une troisième
plus élevée au canada dans toutes les
provinces le québec est le troisième
plus élevée au canada
la dette brute 46% quand on enlève
certains éléments la dette nette c'est
40 % du pib mais sa baisse
l'objectif est de le faire baisser de
faire baisser cette date là
fonds des générations servi à ça on a
fait aussi un remboursement de 10
milliards de dollars à partir du fonds
des générations
donc la dette baisse les niveaux
d'intérêt le niveau d'intérêt le service
de la dette baisse également y est
encore à 9 milliards est encore quand
même assez élevé mais il est moins élevé
que ce qu'il était il ya quatre ou cinq
ans gerald ouvrons une parenthèse sur le
fonds des générations j'entends des gens
dire qu'est ce que c'est on s'en
souvient pas c'était sur le sous jean
charest on avait créé
expliquez-nous la logique c'est plutôt
payer tout de suite la dette
on met ça dans un fond c'est là qu'est
ce qui fait fructifier ça aussi ça va
être plus payant pour opérer un jour la
dette
vous l'avez bien expliquer ça existe
depuis 2006
on met de l'argent ce qu'on appelle des
fonds dédiés donc redevance sur l'eau
par exemple d'hydro-québec sa balade
dans les surplus une partie des surplus
peut aller là dedans il ya différents
fonds qui sont pris à chaque année est
plutôt que d'utiliser ces fonds là pour
investir ailleurs parce que c'est quand
même c'est quand même beaucoup d'argent
c'est des milliards de dollars on le met
dans le fonds des générations s'est
donné l'obligation légale de médecins
dans le fonds des générations
donc ça fait baisser la dette sur papier
on peut rembourser une partie de la
dette mais en fait ça fait baisser la
dette sur papier et ça permet au
gouvernement de modifier cet argent la
sélection de déboucler offre plus élevée
que les coûts d'emprunt donc il ya
évidemment et c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement était critique et de
rembourser 10 milliards parce que le
gains en intérêts sur le remboursement
de la dette en prenant de l'argent dans
le fonds des générations est plus faible
que le rendement qu'on fait est qu'on a
fait y compris en 2018 on a fait quatre
ennemis % de rendement donc on fait des
gains plus importants en investissant
que le gain qu'on fait en intérêts en
prenant 10 milliards pour rembourser
très bien sébastien le milieu économique
réagit comme un bien très bien il y en a
même qui donne une note de aa à aa au
ministre eric girard pour son premier
examen de bulles budgétaires pour
comprendre que le milieu économique
avait plusieurs préoccupations pénurie
de main d'oeuvre notamment on y répond
en disant que les travailleurs
d'expérience c'est comme ça qu'on les
appelle les genres de 60 ans et plus
pourront avoir un crédit d'impôt pour
sur le marché du travail les immigrants
aussi une meilleure intégration des
immigrants il ya des dizaines de
millions $ qui sont consacrés à ça et je
sais qu'en région est un cri du coeur
pour dire amenez-nous de la main
d'oeuvre et on compte notamment sur
l'immigration donc les signaux qui sont
envoyées sont deux passions en général
très bons écoutants quelques règles
c'est un budget qui est très robuste qui
reflète la solidité de l'économie du
québec et le contrôle des finances
publiques
c'est un budget qui reflète une maturité
sociale qu'on a ou québec
c'est un budget qui investit dans la
population active qui va faire en sorte
que la formation soit bien arrimé avec
les besoins du marché du travail
notamment au niveau du sujet c'est ce
qu'on demandait c'est un budget qui vont
inciter des personnes qu'on appelle des
travailleurs d'expérience à rester sur
marché du travail on est sur les bons
thèmes les bonnes mesures
mais ce gouvernement veut vraiment
maintenir et assurer la croissance des
emplois dans le secteur manufacturier il
va falloir avaler une étape plus loin qu
investir davantage investir comme par
exemple à la question de la main
d'oeuvre la ronde c'est le québec qui
est du 1000 emplois vacants au québec
dans le secteur manufacturier
on parle de crédit des crédits pour les
travailleurs expérimentés pour les pme
il faudrait élargir cette mesure-là aux
grandes entreprises pour qu'elles leur
bénéfice eu également un bon budget qui
répond à plusieurs des demandes
le cpq a fait que plusieurs employeurs
ont fait parce que c'est un budget qui 1
continue de viser lesquels et budgétaire
de réduire le poids de la dette
quand même assez prudent dans ses seins
dans ses perspectives économiques qui
dit économie à les entreprises vont se
reconnaître dans ce budget je tirais à
saveur économique ont bien réglé en
partie des enjeux de main d'oeuvre
notamment des travailleurs expérimentés
on est des terrariums on adoucit les
entreprises qui vont vouloir les
embaucher on a mis l'effort sur un
climat d'affaires je pense qu'ils vont
aider les entrepreneurs pensons
notamment la réglementation à simplifier
les processus on veut aussi qu'en région
des entreprises plus mieux
le rsa c'est évidemment très positif ou
sinon c'est un très bon budget pour
l'économie québécoise c'est un budget
qui présente une approche équilibrée
entre remettre de l'argent dans les
poches des contribuables une saine
gestion des finances publiques et aussi
des investissements pour les entreprises
la hausse à vos portes et donc je pense
qu'en ce sens là ça va être très bien
accueilli par les pme bon mais vous avez
raison une note de aa à a+
du côté du milieu des affaires ça c'est
amusant d'entendre quelqu'un dire c'est
un budget à saveur économique
j'espère c'est plutôt rare qu'un budget
ne soit pas à saveur économique les
syndicats
est-ce qu on est aussi content le
discours est différent chez les
syndicats parce que ce qu'on dit c'est
que oui un investissement santé en
éducation notamment mais on réinvestit
surtout dans le béton dans les écoles
par exemple pour l'arrivée des
maternelles quatre heures c'est une
chose ça prend beaucoup d'argent et
aurait investi pas nécessairement dans
les conditions de travail des employés
du réseau public ont réinvesti - par
exemple dans la fonction publique que
dans le réseau de l'éducation de la
santé ce qui soulève certaines questions
des fonctionnaires notamment
voici trois raisons c'est décevant c'est
un budget de béton pourra combler un peu
les fixations du du 1er mai nice et ça
va soulager à peu prés pôles et
travailleuses des travailleurs des
grands réseaux qui ont été affectée ces
dernières années par les mesures
d'austérité
quand tu regardes de façon macro il ya
une croissance des dépenses en santé de
5.4 en une en éducation s'est assuré
pour les prochaines années au niveau des
coûts de système mais en même temps
quand on garde c'est quoi des projets
ont construit des maternelles 80 ont
construit des places en ch sld pour 900
lits de plus des maisons des années qui
vont répondre aux besoins de près de
3000 personnes
mais pour le personnel pour les gens
vont présente et y auriez de
significatif là dedans ça serait
malhonnête de dire que c'est un mauvais
budget de plus il va beaucoup les
fonctionnaires en taxi déjà compétents
qui sont fiers de leur travail aussi
c'est bien mais par contre on devant les
parents pauvres de l'afrique dans les
trois réseaux on augmente c'est pour çà
6% en éducation en santé mais nous c'est
la moitié seulement
vous donc les fonctionnaires c'est ça
oui le résultat possible et qui augmente
ses budgets de dépenses de 3 % seulement
et nous on voulait des réinvestissements
merci france santé en éducation on est
au delà un peu d'une augmentation des
coûts de système mais ce qu'on constate
c'est que en éducation c'est surtout
infrastructures nivellement de la taxe
scolaire et les maternelles de quatre
ans qui viennent une grande part du
budget donc on a droit à autant santé en
éducation à une macédoine de plus
petites buzzer dison b mois un sébastien
voilà moi je continue dans les neuf
prochains pour le monde syndical frères
les notes chiffrées par contre où est
tournée pour les aînés on le dit plus
tôt alors par contre on a l'impression
que la ministre est efficace la wii a
plus on va dire pour les aînés moi je
pense que c'est la première fois que je
passe un extrait unique des gens qui
représentent les aînés se dire la fadoq
la création des aînés du québec parce
que en effet c'est un peu noël au mois
de mars pour eux ils ne s'attendaient
pas à voir autant mesure pour les soins
à domicile par exemple pour les
travailleurs expérimentés pour les
ramener sur le marché du travail de
place au ch et celle des
l'investissement dans les maisons des
aînés aussi qui est un engagement ferme
du gouvernement
alors ce sont d'excellentes nouvelles
pour eux c'est un peu la surprise de ce
budget pour eux à priori au départ on
écoute leurs représentants
on se réjouit de la collaboration qu'on
a fait avec le gouvernement cas qui a
donné des fruits que porter ses fruits
pour une fois les indices ont considéré
dans un budget écoutez on a quand même
deux points 5 milliards qui est investi
pour 5 1 le grand maman cac et a envoyé
un message c'est important de soutenir
les aînés et la qualité de vie de ces
gens nous alors on ne peut que se
réjouir si ce gars y est parfait dans ce
monde s'y met dans les grandes lignes
qu'on avait on parlait des prochains
dernier quelque chose on parlait des
soins domicile à la même affaire les
travailleurs d'expérience alors nous en
quelque sorte que l'on n'ait on se
réjouit de qu'est ce qu'on a vu ce matin
alors ça c'est vraiment sébastien de la
musique aux oreilles du gouvernement
legault d'entendre cette création de la
ville adopte une marguerite blais qui a
bataillé fort pour l'imaginent on
imagine déjà les ceintures eu lieu
le bureau de monsieur gérard merci à
tout de suite gerald ce avait rencontré
le ministre donc oui plutôt
exact vous l'avez vu sourire le ministre
a au début de son budget sourire franc
un homme très heureux de présenter ce
budget il était il était très fier je
vous dirais et il est très candide aussi
en pose des questions il donne des
réponses alors c'est assez agréable à
interviewer j'ai demandé par exemple
vous vous dégager des marges de
manoeuvre pour baisser les impôts dans
le fond voici sa réponse
ses cibles ambitieuses donc jeu savant
la prochaine élection aux promesses
électorales si l'état aux employés vous
y pensez vous aussi ou ou après la
prochaine eric oui ça pourrait être le
programme la prochaine se souvient loi
de ne pas le faire de promettre le faire
et après on le fait vous avez parlé du
programme vers aussi wii roulez vers et
rénovert voici ce qui nous est dit là
dessus et les non verts
rénovert on/off plus j'ai un il ya ainsi
terminé j'ai une heure et s'est terminée
dans ce budget j'ai une encadré qui
explique qu'on a plusieurs programmes
complémentaires on a plusieurs
programmes dédiés à la rénovation et le
31 mars il n'ya plus le programme redman
on sait effectivement y avait le
l'ancien gouvernement avait prévu qui se
termine une fusion la main conservons ce
faire je dois dire que la rénovation
votre avis au québec ce n'est pas
nécessaire alors c'est important de dire
que ça fait partie rénovert tous les
programmes
ce sont des programmes climatique ce
sont des programmes de rénovation
d'économie d'énergie d'environnement
rouler vert va se terminer en 2021 dans
le cadre actuel sera transformé ensuite
mais rouler vert quand on parle des
sommes aujourd'hui en environnement une
grosse partie de ces sommes là c'est le
programme roulait vers qui vous permet
d'avoir une subvention pour l'achat d'un
véhicule électrique alors qu'on a
annoncé à deux jours une autre
subvention qu'ils allaient s'ajouter
celle du gouvernement fédéral
exo celle du québec donc là ça commence
à être des montants dus au québec ça va
faire douze treize mille dollars
commence est vraiment intéressant pour
les gens qui veulent faire ce virage
vers les voitures électriques
merci à tout de suite le bois debout
directeur du département de fiscalité m
versés de sherbrooke est avec nous
dimanche soir bonsoir monsieur coin
alors appréciation générale analysé mois
sur comment vous avez perçu ce premier
budget de la cac est un premier budget
qui reste prudent dans l'ensemble ils
mettent en oeuvre les promesses qu'ils
avaient annoncé durant la campagne
électorale donc c'est plutôt bien et on
est surtout beaucoup plus ciblées pour
ce premier budget qu'on ne l'était la
dernière année où il y avait une
panoplie d'initiatives
je pourrais vous dire par exemple on a
diminué au moins par trois le nombre de
pages donc à trois fois moins de pages
aujourd'hui qui en avait dans le même
exercice il ya un an peine plus direct
plus ou moins de flafla parce que des
fois dans un budget ya de l'enflure
verbale aussi beaucoup et on a ajouté
plein de petites mesures vous dit si on
est allé quoi l'essentiel santé
éducation les années et aussi dans les
mesures fiscales donc vouloir jouer sur
l'incitation au travail des gens de 60
ans et plus donc la mesure l'initiative
est ciblée du côté et des travailleurs
et des pme qui embauchent ce type de
personne la bombe est justement parlez
moi de cette mesure fiscale va pas
tarder des mesures fiscales le budget
mais celle là
semble importante est ce que ça va
changer quelque chose et pourquoi alors
ce qu'on observe quand on regarde le
marché du travail québécois pour toutes
les catégories d'âge de 20 à 59 ans les
taux d'emploi sont toujours meilleures
au québec qu'en ontario qu'on parle des
20 ans des 30 ans des 41 des 50 ans
toujours meilleures au québec en ontario
mais qu'on arrive dans les 60 64 ans 65
à 69 ans on s'aperçoit que les taux
d'emploi sont plus faibles pour toutes
sortes de raisons historiques et l'aja
prennent leur retraite plus tôt au quick
outil de liberté 55 ou quelque chose
existe et des jours sans
ici ça n'existait peut-être ce qu'on a
déclaré by des des régimes de retraite
donc les retraites sont plutôt ici et là
le ministre il avait déjà joué dans le
passé les libéraux avaient mis en place
un crédit d'impôt pour travailleurs
d'expérience il change de nom
aujourd'hui pour le crédit d'impôt pour
la prolongation de carrière et le
ministère ajoute de l'argent donc des
cons à 60 ans c'est possible d'effacer
de l'impôt sur un dix mille dollars au
taux le plus bas du bar et m donc ça
peut inciter des gens à rester sur le
marché du travail et on se tourne aussi
du côté des entreprises attendait mais
je reste sur la première partie de votre
équation là pour des gens qui disent par
exemple c'est pas tellement plus payant
rester au travail d'aller à la retraite
pour moi ça va devenir plus payant
travaillez vous dites on vient on vient
dacquois pour les gens de 60 ans l'année
passée il n'était pas du tout
admissibles à cette mesure-là
émerveillement et nbc pour avoir une
économie de 1500 $ et donc si on parle
de gens à faible revenu
le budget fédéral de mardi derrière
aussi mise en place d des changements
dans le supplément de revenu garanti et
donc les deux budgets viennent de donner
un coup de pouce aux travailleurs
faiblement rémunérés pour s'ils veulent
rester sur le marché du travail que ce
soit plus attrayant que ce ne l'était
par le passé et c'est 1 1 un gros coup
un moyen coup ça veut dire c'est un
incitatif majeur ça va aider un peu
comment on peut évaluer l'impact d'une
mesure comme celle là dans le fond la
mesure elle existait déjà pour les 65
ans et plus il n'y a pas eu de
bonification donc la mesure reste telle
qu'elle est à part le changement fédéral
budget de mardi et pour les autres et on
rajoute on bonifie le led et donc ça ça
devient plus significatif mais ce qu'on
vient faire aussi c'est qu'on se tourne
du côté des pme et on l'a redit il ya
peut-être des coûts embaucher des
travailleurs d'expérience parce que les
gens veulent pas travailler à temps
complet et donc on donne un crédit
d'impôts pour les pme
un crédit d'impôt qui est remboursable
et qui peut effacer dans le fond une
grande partie des cotisations que les
employeurs doivent payer lorsqu'ils
embauchent des travailleurs donc les
cotisations au régime des rentes
c'est important et c'est un incitatif
employer des gens plus âgés
puis ça ça va leur coûter moins cher
c'est çà et là ça c'est nouveau il n'y
avait pas de mesures de ce côté-là a
mené jusqu'à maintenant et la louve pour
les pme et donc pour le moment de cibler
aux pme pour peut-être pour des raisons
de coût mais un jour peut-être qu'on
ouvrira à l'ensemble des entreprises là
vous allez nous expliquer quelque chose
d'autre bourn a vu le minage ira avec
ses souliers de course hier dire je veux
rattraper l'écart de la richesse entre
le québec et l'ontario les salaires
moyens plus bas au québec qu'en ontario
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans ce budget là qui
va aider le québec à rattraper l'ontario
voyez ces sites
le midi s'il y avait des souliers de
course mais vous comprenez que c'est
c'est pas un sprint qui doit faire c'est
un marathon et donc ces mesures là il y
avait déjà commencé dans la mise à jour
économique notamment en favorisant
l'investissement des entreprises dans du
nouveau matériel donc les entreprises
lorsqu'elles investissent dans des
nouveaux équipements
elles puissent l'amortir beaucoup plus
rapidement c'est le fer de lance si les
entreprises ont du meilleur équipement
ce que les entrevues les employés vont
pouvoir produire pour chacun travaille
et va s'accroître
sinon dans le budget d'aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas des tonnes de mesures pour
améliorer la productivité des
entreprises c'est plus que ce qui a été
fait dans la mise à jour économique
ici c'est plus pour l'emploi des
travailleurs d'expérience qu'est ce
qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui les gens qui
se posent la question à quand les
baisses d'impôts comment vous voyez là
la trame à partir de maintenant la les
la caq a promis essentiellement pour les
individus trois choses des réductions de
taxes scolaires c'est fait
l'abolition de contribution
additionnelle pour les frais de garde
mais la bonification des allocations
famille les taxes scolaires c'est fait
bien que on va annoncer dans les
prochaines années de quelle manière ça
sera réduit mon premier cas tiers on
avoir réduit 2 sur 4 pour la
contribution additionnelle de frais de
garde on a annoncé aujourd'hui que dès
cette année les touts les familles qui
gambadent 70 mille dollars ne payent
rompu la contribution très de garde et
progressivement d'ici 2022 ça soit
l'ensemble des ménages à revenus plus
élevés qui sera extrait de cette
contribution additionnelle là pour la
location famille lieu un montant qui
était majoré dans la mise à jour est
connu on devrait ajouter 500 $ pour le
deuxième et troisième enfant mais on est
là on ne pourra à ce jour on n'a pas le
plan pour qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
pour respecter la promesse pour les
quatre prochaines années
je vous rappelle la promesse en gros
c'était 2-2 rendre l'aide pour le
deuxième et troisième enfant aussi
généreux que pour le premier hélas pour
le moment il n'y a pas de plan de match
seul digne et ont pas de nulle part qui
voulait pas le faire
ils vont probablement l'annoncé l'année
prochaine ou l'année suivante mais pour
le moment on n'a pas la séquence des
baisses d'impôts pour les allocations
famille pour les aînés il ya une
ouverture on parle de bonifier le crédit
pour métier à domicile mais pour le
moment y auriez de nouveaux noms mais
les aînés on a vu leur réaction pour ce
qui est du des soins de miss et oui dans
le secteur de la santé puis le personnel
est en fait le nombre de lits en chsld
et là on est on est on semble satisfait
oui parce que moi je vous parle la
fiscalité bien commencé beaucoup plus de
choses que l'ex calmy rey oui
effectivement on rajoute 1.5 milliard le
service à domicile
1.1 millions dans le personnel soignant
près d'un demi milliard ou plus d'un
demi milliard la maison aux aînés donc
c'est clair que c'est des sommes qui
vont profiter aux années mais sur le
plan fiscal il ya peu de changements
pour les aînés dans ce budget si bien qu
on ouvre positivement des changements
dans le futur legault de bouge rappelle
directeur département de fiscalité à
l'université de sherbrooke est
d'ailleurs godbout il y en a de moins en
moins des mesures fiscales dans les
budgets étaient autrefois
est ce que c'est une impression condac
en avait davantage et que la cedh et
d'autres genres de mesures des mesures
de bien sûr de programme on dit où on va
où on va mettre l'argent
mais que des mesures d révolution
fiscale il y en a pas tant que ça vous
en soyez m'est jamais arrivé là mais moi
je souhaitais une réforme de la
fiscalité et qu'on fasse le ménage vous
dites que moins de mesures fiscales mais
le danger que les mesures fiscales c'est
qu'il s'ajoute elle s'ajoute d'une année
sur l'autre et elles se superposent et
en quantité il y en a quand même près de
300 au québec seulement là et donc est
ce qu'il ya des mesures qui pourraient
fait à moins de 100 contribuables
c'est ce ménage là que je souhaitais et
que je souhaite toujours et d'avoir
moins de mesures fiscales mais d'avoir
des mesures fiscales plus efficace et
plus performante et plus généreuse
le code vous remercie beaucoup on
apprend joie d'avoir alors un est
visitable chelsea roger re bonsoir c'est
intéressant d'entendre monsieur votre
boule sur le chemin n'est pas tout à
fait rené vézina parcouru pour ce qui
est des engagements allocations
familiales entendent y en aura d'autres
à venir
il n'y a pas de serrer toutes ses
munitions le ministre au nom me
recommence et ça ça doit être graduelle
ça va être progressif mais il l'a c'est
déjà annoncé donc que ça soit dans un an
deux ans trois ans comme pour
l'élimination complète des contributions
additionnelles auprès de garderie c'est
en marche alors c'est déjà ça c'est pour
ça qu'on va pouvoir dire que on ne sera
pas que l'ensemble des engagements sont
remplis mais que l'essentiel s'y
trouvent
je reviens sur deux éléments pas dead
intéressant on parlait en début
d'émission de l'arrimage possible entre
des mesures du gouvernement fida et
celle ci
mais dans le cas des voitures
électriques c'est le cas on vous l'avait
mentionné donc pour ce qui est du québec
en tout cas on est après treize mille
dollars comme l occasion c'est
considérable et pour l'accès à internet
haute vitesse est un élément dont on n'a
pas parlé mais on veut ainsi tous les
projets d'ici 2023
et ça c'est un demande des municipalités
surtout les municipalités en région
rurale fédéral c'est 2030 je me gêne
qu'on va se parler pour accélérer alors
si tu as un élément intéressant parce
qu'il y avait là tu une fracture
potentiel il risquait et joie bien sûr
un élément d'actualité
on a ici glissé rapidement en début mai
un milliard de dollars dans une
enveloppe pour accompagner pour soutenir
des entreprises stratégiques qui
pourraient faire l'objet
ou de se faire courtiser éventuellement
faire acheter
on pense inévitablement inévitablement
snc lavalin ça c'est pas mal d'argent et
je pense qu'on veut se prémunir du genre
de crise comme on a vécu vous les gens
déchirent leur chemise parce qu'un
fleuron sans délai c'est une somme
intéressante qui pourrait permettre
d'agir en temps et lieu un autre coup
sympa ce que vous devriez plutôt un pied
michel serge il ya beaucoup de coussins
long et allemand oui il y avait
tellement surplus qu'on s'est créé des
coussins des imprévus de ce type la
racheter rapidement dans les actions de
snc lavalin si les chinois veulent
acheter
oui on a fait ça mais c'est vous ce que
ça va compliquer pour pour monsieur
legault ils sont au gouvernement ça va
compliquer ses relations qu'un
gouvernement fédéral parce que l'or on
l'a dit tout à l'heure je pense et c'est
là c'est qu'ils n'y a pas un
gouvernement au canada qui peut se
permettre de telles dépenses
imaginée à partir de maintenant on n'a
pas assez d'argent pour le tramway à
québec et vous l'aviez l'argent vous
avez fait d'autres choix
je n'ai pu nous voir nous à ottawa et on
est dans une élection en alberta un des
thèmes de l'élection va être la
péréquation c'est évident de jason
kenney a déjà annoncé qu'il voulait
faire un référendum sur la péréquation a
imaginé avec des surplus comme ça même
si c'est pas tout à fait juste de mêler
la péréquation à ça combien le débat sur
la péréquation va devenir compliqué à
partir de m chirurgien en conclusion le
on va se retrouver au 17 heures mais
l'accueil est bon on l'a vue là les bons
et les aînés c'est évident les milieux
d'affaires sont très contents syndicats
ont des réserves mais qu'en même temps
on déchire pas notre mise
politiquement cette install thèse quoi
vous êtes réussi pour le minet gerra
politiquement écouter avec les shows
plus qu'il avait il ne pouvait pas
marquer sont celles que ça ça complique
la vie avec la fédéral par exemple
offrir surveiller sa wii pieters avait
déjà été le cas souvenez vous quand jean
charest va annoncer ces baisses d'impôts
oui elle le grand fédéral avait dit ben
si c'est pour que vous nous demandez
après sur le déséquilibre ce cadre il a
pris l'argent du déséquilibre social
pour baisser les impôts ça va pas très
bien passé à 3,1 des conclusions pour
cette banque tu comptes premier budget
je pense c'est un exercice réussi
il faudra voir dans les détails même
s'il est moins gros ce budget faudra
envoyer des mesures ciblées un peu
partout mais moi je pense que
donniez couanau de ab - il ya eu des
fois des notes de co2 dès qu'ils ont été
attribués par des commentateurs
alors je pense que dans l'ensemble on
pourra voir et comme michel disait quand
on nage dans l'abondance sait qu'on est
capables d'en faire un tour et d'un beau
gilet de sauvetage ses bénéfices le cac
vit très bien merci beaucoup on se
retrouve plus tard ou 17h messieurs
gérald de conclusions pour cette
émission
cette partie d'émission oui ma mission
mission il doit être à temps parce que
j'étais en train de parler
il n'y a pas fini son discours mais il
ya du parlé à beaucoup de gens des
milieux d'affaires des syndicats des
groupes des pôles interrogations les
municipalités on verra qu'est ce qu'on
dirait de ce côté là mais sinon plutôt
bien reçus oui absolument
cela dit les milieux d'affaires aurait
aimé la baisse d'impôt tout de suite
mais il a plutôt joué de prudence sur la
baisse d'impôts et c'est assez sage
parce que il avait une possibilité
d'aller de l'avant avec une baisse
d'impôts immédiatement il se dit contenu
du message qu'on voyait la coalition
avenir québec
il se dit investi dans des missions
fondamentales les aînés l'éducation la
santé les infrastructures faut que je
m'occupe de la main d'oeuvre du manque
de main-d'oeuvre également
vieillissement de la population du
ralentissement de l'économie qui est en
cours présentement on sent que le
ministre a voulu jouer de prudence
avec ce premier budget aujourd'hui très
bien gérald on se retrouve bien sûr aux
17 heures merci beaucoup de toutes ces
explications toujours claire a tout de
suite mesdames et messieurs on va se
retrouver donc de l'autre côté avec
toute l'actualité il ya seuil à d'autres
choses parce que ça brasse pas mal
aujourd'hui à ottawa
vous avez vu peut-être gène philpot qui
a retiré une torpille en direction de
son chef justin trudeau
ce n'est pas terminé cette histoire
decency lavalin ottawa d'autres
nouvelles également que l'on suit alors
à tout de suite
merci au revoir sur le marché de
l'emploi des travailleurs qui ne
demandent pas mieux que de continuer à
travailler
j'annonce une bonification du crédit
d'impôt pour travailleurs d'expérience
et un abaissement à 60 ans de l'âge
d'admissibilité à ce crédit d'impôt de
crédit d'impôt s'appellera dorénavant
crédit d'impôt pour la prolongation de
qu'ailleurs afin de mieux refléter
l'objectif de cette mesure fiscale
près de cent cinquante huit mille
travailleurs pourront profiter de cette
mesure dès 2010 ne s'annonce également
une réduction des charges sur la masse
salariale liée aux salaires versés à des
travailleurs âgés de 60 ans ou plus
cette réduction profitera à 34000 pmm de
tous les secteurs d'activité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs voici ce
qui marque l'actualité maintenant hier
éric girard présente un budget équilibré
sans baisses d'impôts avec des
augmentations de dépenses de plus de 5%
en santé et en éducation tous les
québécois votent au budget a été défini
à part